[Music]
new zealand's catholic church reveals
the extent of abuse allegations oh is it
some kid touching [ __ ] again it is some
kid touching
again
revealing the list though which is cool
it's not what you think though
this is the kids touch the adults oh no
way
i bet they do
right the other way around because
because i have a batch of psychology and
we learned that
when children abuse like sexual abuse
not all children obviously but i also
think it's a certain age they enjoy it
they know it's wrong because there's
that you know tenseness and all that and
anxiety but they enjoy it and so kind of
like stockholm syndrome yeah but they
don't talk about it because there's a
guilt about it yeah there's a there's a
total guilt about it and so but they
there are kids that enjoy it um
and you know and i'm not saying i'm not
trying to paint a picture that they're
they're sick disgusting no you should
print it and put it on a shirt
there are kids that like it i was abused
and i enjoyed it
so i i um i learned it too because i i
have a batch in psychology oh you do too
it was in the sexual psychology side
where it was like when they get groomed
to do this stuff
it's like that weird introduction to it
so then even though it's like kind of
wrong and weird what ends up happening
is that's what they associate uh
sexuality with that kind of abuse and
then so they live a lifetime and that's
why they say typically people who have
been uh molested or whatever as a child
end up becoming uh
the same patterns though it's a pattern
then the cycle keeps going and it's just
this weird like cycle that yes that's
like never ending yeah you guys are
smarter than me i was just thinking
about how sometimes i see a baby and he
like is holding a titty
and he doesn't even know and i'm always
like that lucky little baby
you get jealous of a baby yeah hell yeah
dude i thought
i thought holding holding a titty was
very pg for you yeah you don't thank you
it was a titty twist in it
the catholic church from new zealand has
now admitted that 14
of the and i'm not familiar with this
word because i'm an idiot but diocesan
clergy
mm-hmm have been accused diocese like
diocese the people from the diocese i
think i can say that perfect thank you
uh have been accused of abuse against
children and adults since 1950 so that's
14. wait is it is it just the new
zealand group this is the new zealand
catholic church yeah [ __ ] so it's it's
like a worldwide pedophile thing what
was the number again 14 14
of the clergy
that's a [ __ ] time dude in addition the
report shows 8 percent of male
congregational members had complaints
made against them while three percent of
female congregational members were the
subjects of claims so those are the ones
that are talking by the way
yes
exactly exactly so when they say three
percent are female they're saying that
of the
assaulters are three percent female yeah
well the claims are against three people
that makes sense because what boy like
of like of right age
or like of right mind at a certain age
if a woman touches them are they gonna
report it doesn't report it because
they're actually gonna brag about it
yeah 100
that's why they report it mother teresa
touched me all over the place
but don't but don't tell nobody
like hey mother teresa saw my dick
you guys are all going to hell really uh
we're not talking about the same teresa
oh that's right there's a lot of
teresa's out there
at least when i get there i won't see
mother teresa because that would be
awkward that would be that would be
great
why are you doing down here
because dudes would just they can't wait
to [ __ ] brag to all their friends
like hey you know what [ __ ] sister
marianne did and [ __ ]
she sounds hot totally it's totally
different
that sounds like i want to know a sister
marianne [ __ ] his sister mary
clarence and [ __ ]
yeah
from sister act whippy goldberg
clarence that was one of my favorite
movies
even sister act 2 was good the
soundtrack was amazing i watched both
those movies 100 times easily i used to
think catholics were way more fun than
yeah yeah yeah because my church was
boring man we didn't [ __ ] dance and
sing and [ __ ] it was just sad church was
miserable yeah and i was like damn
catholics have all the fun dude they're
more progressive
yeah you have to say that they are
really funny
of the
1680 complaints on the record 80
involved children
over half of all complaints were reports
of sexual harm against a child and the
report draws on records from 428
catholic parishes 370 catholic schools
and 67 care institutions in new zealand
damn there's that many
buildings in new zealand that's crazy
when i think of new zealand i think of
like a long strip of land island and
wallabies and like two things
you know what you know
i was stupid for thinking you said when
i think of new zealand i was stupid to
think you were gonna say like lord of
the rings and hobbits
but then i remember you don't watch any
movies he'll get around to it he'll get
around to it he's like what what is that
lord of the what
i know harry potter
wait have you seen lord of the rings no
oh
dude welcome to how fun it is to sit
here and try to talk about movies with
these [ __ ] dude it's it's a
blast
i watched the good ones though they're
good ones like what toby maguire
spiderman what was the last full what
was the last full movie you watched i've
watched the whole tom holland series
spider-man there's a tom holland series
like the three movies spider-man okay i
got it he watched all three of those
he's also doing this [ __ ] with his kid
where he's trying to get his kid to
watch like old cool kung fu movies so
that he could brag to all of us about
how his kid like loves rumble in the
bronx yeah she likes it though yeah
exactly
this is what goes on it's like super
super sad does he look does he like
francois yep
oh no i don't know if he has i think all
girls are yucky they're still yucky yeah
that's a deep cut dude
it's difficult for me to bring it back
to this topic after talking about it
yeah
it's a great topic though yeah we really
should get back
yeah let's talk more about this we
should touch on it some more yeah touch
is also a really fun word and is it are
we even still surprised that there's
[ __ ] catholic church stuff that keeps
coming out all the time i feel like
every week dude there's always some
catholic church stuff that just can't
stop molesting people i think anything
over 10
is like pretty pretty that's pretty wild
but what's funny to me is i'm not
catholic i'm protestant so i feel like i
can say this is like what's funny to me
about catholicism is that they're very
strong on excommunication from the
church like if you miss a day of worship
on sunday you can get excommunicated but
if you touch a little boy a little girl
we'll just move you yeah yeah to a
different church we'll promote you yeah
it's like why not why not excommunicate
these people well aren't they worthy of
god's love
but then hey don't show up for church
you get the [ __ ] out i know right yeah
what do they do they do like communion
and confirmation and what like there's
all these series of ceremonies you have
to do and even if you only do like
two-thirds of it or something before you
turn 18 you can't become like actual
catholic anymore either because if you
if you don't pass all the things yeah
it's like a very like they'll kick you
out real quick yeah
thus you're no longer catholic you like
can't you can't technically say you're
catholic if you don't do although you
say it but they don't accept you
so for example like let's say you're
part of this church
saint padre
padres
like in san diego yeah so you got st
padres and you you grew up going here
and you only finished like i think two
out of the three steps or maybe three
out of four steps then later when you
try to come back and get married there
they go nope you're not part of our
church that's so lame yeah and your
family is usually pressuring you to get
married there and [ __ ] so it [ __ ] you
yeah [ __ ] with you yeah
at least you can you know who's hardcore
and who's not yeah you know it's like
man you ain't that down you're lazy ass
i can just see the comments now yeah i
don't know anything about catholicism
we're experts who does and then what i
want to say to you guys our comment that
is if you're coming here for your
religious like you know knowledge you're
coming to the wrong way and if you're a
catholic expert you're a kid touching
yourself
14 so many people come here for real
information and get disappointed in the
comments dude that's the best yeah dude
what is this harvey ever been right dude
like you know on stage go to joe rogan
yeah exactly dude he's good news that's
where you go
[ __ ] morons
go to neil young he knows all the facts
go to our patreon
we have way more news over there
real facts for sure
i went down this deep dive of um all
this like conspiracy [ __ ] the uh before
it was publicly admitted that there were
kid touchers in the catholic church is
that the professional uh term kid tetris
yeah yeah kid
or child caressers because i thought it
was just in america
i thought it was just in america
exclusively american trade but this is
happening in like italy south america
all these different places right not the
vatican that i've heard nope yeah but
then
there's a there's a lady none a former
nun that came out that used to be in the
vatican and she she was like dude they
had [ __ ] orgies like it was crazy
orgies in the vatican yeah
they would just go ham dude yeah they
get like a [ __ ] house right next to
the vatican and just go off
what i find funny is though is joe
you're saying like they found that globe
globally this is happening you know but
what's funny is like in america we're
like
we have i think like
95 plus percent of all serial killers do
we do
like other countries have theirs here
and there and then now with media it's
different like you can't the statistics
are skewed but prior to like internet
media and all that 24 7 use cycles we
had about like 98 95 to 98 of all serial
killers because they're all they're all
white male 1
well how come how come in europe they
don't do them do they jack the ripper
check the ripper oh that's old but
that's
in your little percent doesn't it yeah
that's that's where that two three
percent comes in yeah it's a big one
that's like ages ago though
but like we've had the most and it's
because you know we we do through no
fault of media but like they do
sensationalize it so people want that
they want that notoriety so they move
over here in order to move yeah i like
to think americans just work hard at
everything that they do so even killers
like they do it by like they're just oh
it's their work ethic yeah it's their
american dream because maybe in the
europe you know like if you're a french
serial killer you probably kill one
person and you're like i need the coffee
you know and just relax just chill yeah
you're just too lazy or else i mean
we're also in america right if you shoot
up a school they're going to post your
manifesto until everyone what your
message was [ __ ] like it's just you know
it's unbelievable and then if they're
white and they shoot up a school they'll
be gently handcuffed
but if they're black and they just
happen to have a knife they'll shoot
them dead because
good all-american american way
we have an excellent police force
according to um the police force
who investigated themselves and found
they did nothing wrong
you know i evaluated myself and i found
myself to be a genius so i don't know
you can take that with a grain of salt
if you'd like but i i evaluated and i'm
a great evaluator so if you want me to
evaluate you i can
i would like that please
i have a very large penis according to
myself
[Music]
you